um
are we live sonia
good evening members welcome to the
review committee meeting um
of rochefort district council and
welcome to everyone
who may be watching online my name is
counselor dave sperring i'll be chairing
this evening's meeting
working down the agenda agenda item one
his apologies for absence
i know we have apologies uh from our
committee chairman councillor
jamie burton who is unwell do we have
anybody else on you
no chairman okay thank you very much
uh moving on to agenda item number two
substitute members are there any members
substituting this evening
don't believe so no chairman no fine
moving on to agenda item number three
non-members attending
uh we have councillors uh smith
williams and fd attending chairman
thank you sonya moving on to agenda item
number four the minutes of the meeting
held
on the 6th of october 2020
can i take those as accepted members or
are there any other issues
that you wish to raise
i can't see any indications of not
accepting them
[Music]
so we'll take those as as accepted sonia
thank you chairman item agenda and
gender item number five to receive
declarations of interest
including any whipping interests are
there any decorations of interest please
members
i can't see any okay that brings us on
to the
the main body of the agenda
um the first item is the
2021 mid year treasury management review
this will be presented by uh ad and 151
officer
miss naomi lucas uh avery supporter i'm
sure by a portfolio holder
counselor simon smith okay now emmy over
to you
thank you chair
the purpose of the report um presented
tonight is to provide an update on the
council's treasury management activity
for the period first of april 2020 to
the 30th of september 2020
in accordance with the council's
treasury management policy and good
practice
uh the mid-year report is has been
prepared in compliance with cyphus code
of practice on treasury
management and covers a number of
different areas that are set up within
the report
i'll just give you a very brief overview
of each section
firstly there is an economic update
which has been provided
in conjunction with our treasury
management advisors
link um members can can read the um body
of the report but in summary it's not
expected that the
bank of england's base rate will change
from 0.1
for the foreseeable future and as a
consequence
investment rates are expected to remain
close to zero
um this does mean that borrowing
interest rates will also
remain historically cheap but as members
will be aware the council does not have
any borrowing currently so um it won't
take advantage of those rights
um the the latest forecasts um
for the base rate and the and the um
pwlb
rates are shown in the tables at
paragraph 3.5 of the report
um the next section summarizes
any key movements or changes to the
council's capital and treasury
strategies
um in summary there is no changes to the
strategy that was approved
um by council on the 11th of february um
this year um so there's no
there's nothing really to report in in
regard in regards to that
um section five of the reports um shows
the potential indicators
um for capital investment and shows a
summary at table 5.1 of the
report which shows the forecasted
outcome for the
council's capital expenditure as at um
30th of september 2020.
there were some changes agreed to the
capital programme um
which were agreed by full council on the
20th of october 2020 and now reflected
in the revised figures shown within that
table
as i mentioned earlier the council
doesn't have any borrowings so there's
nothing to report in regards to that
finally the report shows a summary of
the council's investment portfolio
for the first half of this year um and
the graph
at paragraph 6.3 shows the average
investments held by the authority over
the first six months of the year
members will see that balances were
unusually high at the beginning of the
year
and that is because at the start of the
year the government
transferred around 18 million pounds to
the council to distribute in the form of
small business grants
and they were paid out in the first
couple of months of the year which then
brought
the average investment rates um back
down in line with our normal
expectations
i think that's all i was going to say at
this point but if members have any
questions i'm happy to try and answer
them thank you chair
thank you naomi okay members you've
heard
uh naomi's brief presentation
you've all had the paperwork presented
to you some days ago
are there any questions counselor mrs
mason
thank you mr chairman not a question as
such but i do
um i am pleased to see that the strategy
has remained unchanged
thank you okay members is
is there anybody else wishes to raise
anything
i can't see anybody sonja if you see
anybody
okay members well if there's nothing
else chairman
smith is indicating or all i was going
to say
chairman just for a matter of record
that
as usual our treasury management has
been very well
managed by our officers um particularly
bearing in mind the
circumstances in which we find ourselves
and
just a brief mention that naomi
uh got through in a few a few seconds of
saying we
we we managed to uh allocate 18 million
pounds worth of grant that government
gave us in under two months uh
with a rigorous system i think is
absolutely to be commended
thank you thank you councillor
okay members at the bottom of page
6.7 there is a recommendation
it is proposed that the review committee
recommends the contents of this treasury
management mid-year
report to council if there are any
members
who wish to have a recorded vote please
indicate
otherwise the vote will be done
electronically
please please indicate now if you wish
to have a recorded vote
nobody sonya okay members
if you are in agreement that we
push this recommendation forward to full
council
would you please indicate by raising the
right
of your blue hand now
okay
is there anybody against this uh
recommendation
please indicate now
chairman if people could lower their
hands first please would you like your
lower your blue hands please members
anybody not supporting this
recommendation please
indicate now by raising your new hand
no anybody abstaining please raise your
blue hand now
thank you chairman that's a that's a
grade thank you members
thank you naomi and uh counselor smith
moving on to agenda item number seven
uh unfortunately our
id counselor marcus hotten
is unwell and will not be able to be
here this evening
but has sent along his able substitute
ms
leslie athey who will be making the
presentation
supported uh by councillor williams
and reading out to consider the report
of the working group of the review
committee who have developed
a waste and recycling strategy ahead of
the expiry of the council's
current waste and recycling contract in
march
2022 okay leslie i appreciate you've
been thrown in at the deep end with
marx's non-appearance but over to you
thank you chair
good evening my name's leslie assey i'm
principal street scene officer standing
in for marcus
this evening i'm going to explain how
the waste and recycling strategy was
developed
and the steps that were taken and to
explain some of the background to the
report
i'll also try to answer any questions
that the members may have
um overall the purpose of the report is
as councillor sparring has pointed out
is to agree the
new waste and recycling strategy that
sets out the council's goals
for future waste management services
the current waste contract is due to
expire in march 2022
and the council will need to procure a
new service and the strategy underpins
this
so pages one to nine of the report
is an introduction and provides the
background to the work that was carried
out by the member working group
member working group was set up about a
year ago and they've been reviewing
the current waste collection services
and looking at
future options for collections
through the work of this group the new
strategy has been developed
the group looked at various influencing
factors including various strategic
drivers and key principles
they looked at different waste
collection methods and these collection
methods
were modeled to test their effectiveness
and the impact on costs
and the recycling rate from this a draft
strategy was drawn up
mr t sorry the
strategic drivers were financial
considerations
and comparisons were made to the cost of
the current
service those financial considerations
were the age of the existing vehicle
fleet
and the cost of new new vehicles
because the old fleet will need
replacing
the increase on demand from an expanding
population
the sale of commodities which is the
recycled materials
that we collect and changes in
legislation
that's things like the national minimum
wage and also environmental
legislation
at national legislation um currently
has a target recycling rate set at 50
but that's increasing to 65 by 2035.
the council has statutory duties to
collect the waste
um and to collect some of that waste for
recycling so it's compulsory that we do
that
as well as collecting other types of
household waste
there is also an agreement with essex
county council
which we need to fulfill where various
payments are made for diversion of
waste from landfill
and the environment the national
environment bill is driving greater
separation of waste
by 2023
the group considered various types of
collection including
a mixed recycling collection as we do
currently versus
twin stream collecting two separate
types of recyclables
and also a curbside sort as well as
separate food waste collections
and depending on how materials are
collected
the containers and vehicles and
therefore the costs and recycling rate
will vary
other factors to consider are the
recycling market
itself which is a commodity market
and the group considered whether we
would continue with a separate service
for material
sorting or whether the council would
take responsibility for direct sale
of recycled materials in the future
another key consideration is achieving
carbon neutrality
one of the key contributors to the
carbon footprint of the council is the
collection of waste
so the group considered vehicle types
and reviewed the feasibility of an
all-electric fleet
in the future and it was recognised that
the electric vehicle market is not fully
ready for all electric
waste collections however the strategy
paves the way
for an all-electric fee fleet when the
technology is more developed and ready
for mass market
moving on to page 9 of the report
section
5 the report describes the process of
modelling of collections
that was undertaken to assess the
effectiveness of the various different
collection methods
and to see what impact it would have on
costs and the recycling rate
the current collection service waste
collection service was benchmarked
against other councils
and then an options appraisal looking at
the whole life costs of future
collection schemes was undertaken
the group looked at 10 different
collection methods
and this included alternative collection
frequencies
different vehicle types different
containers and sizes
and greater separation of materials
before they are collected
and the work assess the comparative
comparative costs and recycling
performance of those different
models
moving on to going through this process
the results
which are highlighted on pages 11 to 13
of the report
there are a series of graphs which shows
the
um the output from those different uh
model
options and then page 14 of the report
shows the conclusion of the study
the benchmarking that was undertaken
showed that the current scheme performs
well
when compared with similar local
authorities
and there are various ways in which
collections could be provided in the
future
and the modelling enabled the working
group to test and eliminate some of
those options on the basis
of performance
[Music]
some of the key outcomes of that
exercise were
that introducing separate food waste
collections results in significant
recycling rate increase but separate
food waste collections
also includes it also increases
the cost as separate collection rounds
will be needed
the lowest cost option would be to
continue collecting um
co-mingled recyclables as we do now but
with a fortnightly garden waste
collection and reducing the
the frequency of non-recycling
collections provided the highest
increase
in recycling rate and reduced costs
so taking all of those um
outcomes into consideration uh a
proposed waste strategy
was put forward by the member working
group
it was agreed that a new waste strategy
should deliver the following for our
district
and that is to seek to reduce costs
to comply with legislative requirements
to include a separate food waste
collection
keep the collection scheme simple to
understand and relatively easy to use
for our residents improve the quality of
the recyclables collected and building
flexibility for future changes
and also to consider alternatives to
fossil fuels when economically and
technically
feasible
the member working group also
agreed or proposed a vision the
council's vision which is a leaner and
greener working towards
zero waste and more details of that can
be found on page 17
section 8.
pages 20 to 24 of the report provide the
outcomes of the
options that were modeled in the
appraisal and page 25
is the waste and recycling strategy to
be agreed today
i think all members will have read
read the report um but talking through
the
strategy slides which is from page 25
appendix a
slide two sets the scene in terms of
introducing
rochford and the current situation
slide three is the council's vision
towards leaner and greener
rochford will be making changes to
collect the materials that really matter
looking to make savings increase
recycling rates and head towards carbon
neutral
whilst taking care of people and the
environment and
turning waste into a resource
slides four to six of the strategy
page 28 of the report sets out the
council's
objectives providing a cost efficient
service
and easy to use service residents
meeting
statutory obligations and supporting the
move towards a more
circular economy and reducing carbon
emissions
slides seven to ten are the key
deliverables
which are to anticipate statutory
changes to waste collection by
introducing
a separate weekly food collection
deliverable to reduce garden waste
collection to control service costs
deliverable 3 maximize recycling through
reduced
non-recyclable waste capacity and
deliverable 4
maximize the quality and value of the
recyclables collected
slide seven sorry slide 11 on page 35
this describes how success will be
measured by a series of objectives
and that's my presentation on the
report and the strategy to be approved
thank you thank you leslie that's very
comprehensive
i think the uh the report that we've
already seen and a number of us were
involved in producing
uh covers a lot of issues but obviously
members will have some questions
um but first one counselor michael hoyer
please
oh sorry i keep on muting him using
yourself thank you that accidentally
clicked off the hand as well
um just a couple of things yeah i think
it's very comprehensive report
and very well done congratulations to
the members of the working group who did
this and obviously
the officers um just a a
couple of points really um
i'm sorry i'm sticking to and throw
between the reports
on the same screen which is never that
easy um
it's just um a comment really it sort of
is addressed further on in the report
but the on page
7.1 we have strategic drivers and key
principles
and i was rather surprised that
recycling
in itself wasn't mentioned as a key
driver and a key principle
i think that was probably perhaps that
was missed by its obviousness i don't
know but i think that should have been
there
um obviously recycling is addressed in
the report
um but i don't know why it wasn't there
as a strategic driver and a principal
um moving on to a little bit
further um
there's going to be a question here as
well let's i'm trying to find the page
now 7.27
which is the report itself of um the the
strategy
we have um leaner and greener and i know
i think green there
i think that might be somebody else's
policy as well um
we we aim to collect the stuff that
really matters
i'm not sure what that means what stuff
are we talking about
what stuff matters and what stuff
doesn't it's just we're not collecting
any
there's certain things we're not going
to collect that brings me
around to one of the questions which is
around green waste is is that perhaps
the intention that
green waste won't matter eventually and
we'll start charging for it
um make financial savings fine
increase recycling rates which is
good got no problem with that but if we
look at our targets
um which i'm very pleased to see by the
way i know i always bang on about
targets and that
quite a lot quite often our strategies
and policies don't actually have targets
so i'm very very pleased to see we have
targets here but on
page 7.35 objective
objective 3 the objective is to maintain
rochester district council's recycling
rate over 62 percent
it doesn't actually say we are
the we're going to increase the
recycling rate it just says we're going
to maintain it
so that's slightly contradictory i'd
rather have seen
and i even if it was to to increase it
to the 65
earlier than the government target um i
am aware that it's very
difficult to increase the targets at um
in this country at the moment but um
given that we're also
that the aim is to decrease the total
amount of waste i would hope we should
be able to
increase the percentage of the waste
we're receiving but
by by more than 62
um turn waste into resource again that
comes back to
this question about garden green garden
waste i'll is this an indication that
although it's not talking about
immediately there is a lot of
talk within the report and
about charging this 40 pounds for garden
waste i know this has been looked at
over a few years um i've read reports
from other councils where
the the take-up wasn't as high as 35
mentioned in the report
and that gives there me
some concern um
otherwise i'm quite happy sorry i'm just
reading something on my notes i'm i'm
fairly happy with the report otherwise
it's just some of these contradictions
and
and this dispara disparity between the
sort of the the policy of increasing
recycle rates but the target
is unchanged if i could have an answer
around the the 40 pound charge for the
green waste that's all
thank you i think
uh going back on this uh council ahoy
i think all we're doing is making
recommendations
it'll be up to full council to decide
what course they wish to follow but
uh i don't know if uh if you want to
come in on that arthur
sorry if i could just come in back on
that i'm just raising it because
of this turn wasting results and there's
a lot of talk around
the 40 pounds in there so i think it's a
relevant question we should ask
with how much what if i look at this and
we say turn waste into resource is quite
difficult to do at the moment the most
obvious way from reading the report
is to charge 40 pounds i
i agree the the situation is
all we can do is make recommendation we
cannot
make these proposals firm this will be
down to full council to decide if that's
the route they want to go down
all we can do is give them the various
options to look at
and i would suggest that somewhere along
the line in due course
perhaps another working party will be
put together
to go through what we as have produced
and recommended
or hopefully recommend to to present
full council with a final
uh proposal that the full council can
vote on but
arthur do you wish to come back in on
that one yeah thank you i think this is
more about the quality of the waste that
we collected
um there is considerable contamination
and this is going to help us to to
eliminate that um
it's yes there there is there will be
the in the future there
there will be means to to have a
chargeable
green waste collection of of which isn't
mandatory but
as far as i'm aware we will be requested
by the government be required by the
government to
kill to collect food separately i think
that's correct isn't it leslie
but that's not definite yet but um we
were expecting it this year but
yeah it's likely to be introduced in
2023 a separate food waste collection
yes so yeah that's it on that one thank
you
is is that are you okay with that
michael or do you wish to come back
um where's that yeah there's not
not much point this is the way strategy
is so i'm aware
it's not the the contract or anything
like the contract is just how the
hopefully how a contract would would
have to apply itself
um so there's
not really much to come back on that i
noticed um council williams did mention
about um
education and obviously that has come up
in the past around
around the waist and the contamination
of the bins and i know that was a
particular problem
during the um early days of the pandemic
that there was a lot more contamination
there than they
had been previously um
how what percentage at the moment is
lost to contamination is that known
uh leslie might know that one um we're
it's approximately um nine percent of
the
um recyclables that are collected
at the moment which has it has gone up
um slightly over the uh the last few
years
yes i suppose that goes back to the um
education which is
sort of mentioned within the the
strategy but i think
perhaps we need to i know there was some
talk about new stickers for the bins
but i think perhaps we need to go beyond
that sometimes because it does get
although we do have a one bin strategy
as you say effectively
for recycling it it's still quite
confusing for many people what they can
and can't put in there
and i think they're still con still
confusion around coffee pots
for instance and chris packets still and
which
plastic film can or can't go in the bins
and i think
if we need to go a bit beyond the the
stickers on the bins
because there are so many items now
which cannon the people are looking at
to go in or not to go in
absolutely this is going to be
considered by the um
bin hangers and things like that but
this will be included in the new
contract when it comes
okay thank you arthur i'll go down the
list of of hands as i believe they came
up but if i've got them in the wrong
order i do apologize i think the next
one is councillor mike wilkinson
thank you chad um i'm going to show my
um
newness and the council here and
apologize for asking a question i'm sure
everybody looking at me and already
knows the answer to
could you just confirm uh either leslie
or arthur whichever's um whichever you
use easy to do this
um i fully understand the um the aims
and the ambitions i think that
are expressed within the report and
actually and completely support them
um i just wanted to understand i can see
in front of me i mean i'm looking at
page 20 appendix one
there are three options option one
option two and option three
are we just saying this is the
recommendation for full council at some
point to consider which option they want
to go to
or are we recommending one of those
options because if we're recommending
one of those specific options i've
missed that
as far as i'm aware we're not oh we're
leslie on this one this is just a
recommendation to go to full council
right okay that's that asked me
perfectly thank you
okay thank you i believe the next one
was councillor bob milne
oh yeah thank you chairman um yeah this
is really a
couple of questions for leslie and
arthur really
um obviously the
waste identification for the public is
either very easy generic
or there are some specific items and
that's where we get into a gray area
and we'd already discussed some stage in
the past
uh government looking at uh cue coding
or doing something the packaging and all
that kind of thing
a very simple thing though that has
popped up is i started receiving
professional
society magazines in biodegradable bags
they actually made a potato starch but
they look like they're plastic but
they're not
and they can be made in different colors
so
as part of all of this kind of general
look at this thing i know we're going to
recommend something that's generic to
the council
and something potentially can save money
and protect the environment so we've got
two big things there
so this idea of the biodegradable bags
is just
just to can we uh recommend that we
should pursue looking at something like
this because you could put the food
waste in the pink one in the same bin
when they get to the other end it's very
easy for the workers to go bosh
woo food green bang and another bin
which is all good i fully appreciate the
problems of green waste
and i understand we're one of the few
councils around this part of the world
that don't actually charge for it
um as a reward for this if we were to
reorganize
um the way we deal with it what could be
the potential ball figures
for savings and the advantages that's
just it really i know it's a big
question that one
and that's just it thank you closely i
don't know if you have anything on this
um i think that uh one of the
uh a couple of things really coming out
of the national um
waste resources strategy uh one
is that separate food waste collections
are likely to be mandated and therefore
the bags that you you're describing
we would have to look at whether they
would be accepted
um by the processor at the time and then
perhaps do some publicity around that
[Music]
and another thing that we will be
advocating
is home composting and of course if if a
bag
is compostable then it can go in a home
composter
so that's something that again we would
look at but it would require
some research and publicity
um as far as the costs are concerned
um i couldn't give you a figure off of
my head as to
whether that would have any impact on on
the costs
as such um i think that the separate
food waste collections as
outlined in the report and if you look
at the detail
um it does mention that
there is an additional cost to separate
uh to collect
separate food waste um but that could be
offset by doing something differently
with other parts of the collection
scheme
like every other week that could offset
the cost of dealing with the food that
kind of thing potentially yeah thank you
this will become more apparent when we
go out to
pretend asking for tender on this thank
you
okay thank you bob uh counselor
mrs mason
thank you mr chairman um firstly i'd
like to support
councillor hoy's concern regarding the
green waste and the constant
referrals to the 40 pound cost which
almost
sounds like it's a predetermined figure
and charge which
i then contradicted in the report at 4
14
you put although not yet law the
environment
bill is an indication that the next few
years will see significant
change for local authorities in terms of
waste
mandatory collection scheme changes are
likely to be introduced
separate food waste collected weekly
and possible free garden waste
collection so why we're emphasizing
a charge when the government's um
considering for
a compulsory free garden waste
collection i i'm a little concerned
about
and it goes understand more focus on
recycling quality and separation
and again i would like to support the
previous speakers on this
i think one of the issues that we have
is we do have a contamination rate it
does cost money
and it's done because the council
although
you can look on a website who's going to
look up a web on a website before they
go and put something in a bin
the labels on the bin have disintegrated
years ago
what we need is some constant simple
clarification and communication on a
regular basis
to explain to our residents where we get
the contamination
what the issue is and perhaps focus each
once a week once a month on a particular
item the communication needs to be
greatly improved and it needs to be done
simpler we don't want a little wheel
that we've got to turn around
and clutters up the kitchen we don't
want um to have to look up on a website
we want a simple message that residents
understand and if it means
labeling bins would certainly be a start
but but i think
the communication has not been as
effective as
i would have hoped and presumably if
that is improved
then we would improve our rate of
recyclable
thank you thank you council would you do
you want to come back on that one uh
arthur um yeah it's just that we did
anticipate
re re um stickering the beans at um
earlier this year but
kobe took over i'm afraid um and it is
something that's going to be included in
the education side of it will be taken
into account
with with the new contractors or the
present one if they
tender correctly well i'm pleased to
hear that mr chairman but having
said that i have not had my been
re-stickered
since it was first delivered so it's
something that's well overdue thank you
i i take your point to
council mrs mason um i've also come
across
very close to me a number of temporary
residents in this area
who have come into the district from
other areas have never seen this sort of
system before they're used to putting
everything in a big bag
so we've had to uh you know take the
time to try and educate them but
i think we've all taken on board and as
as councilor williams said
you know there were plans put in place
to try and uh
expedite training and advice and
guidance for
the residents but uh circumstances have
uh have overtaken us on this occasion
but i can assure you from
what we learned to the working group
this is well on the agenda and is one of
the main items that we will
need to address in the short term well
good intentions are all very well mr
chairman but i'd like to see some action
thank you
oh well if i think it's fair to say that
there's enough of us
who want to make this happen it will
happen thank you
council hawkway when
thank you chairman um yes um
i just uh
picked up on something in the report um
it's a little bit concerning
um it's under 4.3
um under the age of existing vehicle
fleet
um it says in the report that um
it says it was noted that uh at present
neither option has yet been modeled
within the current medium-term financial
strategy for the council
is therefore likely to cause an
additional pressures on the budget
position
this relates to the replacement of the
fleet
as to whether it's going to be part of
the contractors
or the council purchasing a new fleet
this might be a bit more of a question
for when the medium-term financial
strategy comes before review because
so it's uh it's concerning that a matter
which
has long been known that this
was going to come up for uh
um to to the con contract was going to
come to
uh to an end um and that um obviously
we are looking ahead to some degree but
um
you know really this there should be
some financial
um uh reserve placed in the medium-term
financial strategy for the potential
such a large
outlay of council funds especially
if the council is going to purchase new
vehicles which is
a highly approp you know high
probability
so i don't know if um anyone wants to uh
make any uh comment back in relation to
that particular aspect in the report
thank you
now we do want to come in on that one or
otherwise i will
um thank you councillor sparring um
yeah i'd i'd just say that um yeah
counselor
is obviously right that we are aware of
the
um budget risks associated with
um providing the appropriate waste
vehicles
um the reason it hasn't been
um explicitly built into mtfs at this
stage is because there is a variety of
options in terms of how we procure
and run those vehicles under
consideration and therefore it's
it's not known with sufficient clarity
at this time whether we would be
purchasing the vehicles ourselves which
would obviously be a capital outlay for
the council
in which case we could look at different
methods of financing it
um or whether it would be provide better
value for money for the contractor
themselves to procure or
run the vehicles which as the report
mentions would obviously have revenue
implications
so i think because we haven't got
sufficient certainty at this time about
the about the method and
the the form of financing those vehicles
we haven't yet built those into
mtfs although it has been noted as a
specific risk and as i say we have got
um sort of a number of options in terms
of how we can finance those available to
us
um but a decision hasn't been made at
this point in time
um and as i think it's been noted
earlier on obviously there is a variety
of um
financial considerations as part of the
wider waste procurement um
race contract procurement and the actual
sort of model of delivery of the
contract itself
um will need to be considered alongside
alongside the vehicles as as part of
that strategy
thank you naomi yeah i mean can i just
quickly just give you a certain
thing um uh yes thank you very much
um uh for for that explanation
it also raises an interesting thing
we've
we've looked at in the previous report
um
about uh the the low current low cost of
borrowing
so um he's um he's
is there strong possibility that the
council may look at um
uh financing something a large
um purchase or potential purchase like
this
uh through uh wholly through borrowing
bearing in mind the interest rate being
so low um
if i may come back on that chair and
obviously our current strategy doesn't
um allow borrowing um however we have a
noted and
discussed at previous review committees
around the treasury strategy
um that it may be advantageous for us to
consider whether we want to continue
that policy into future years as you say
borrowing is at sort of historically low
rates at the moment and obviously we
have to consider that as part of the
wider strategy
but um if the the most effective and
cost-effective way
of of um purchasing the vehicles
if we were to want to do that is is to
borrow um that is something that
the um council could obviously
reconsider
would require the appropriate um
approvals of of the strategy to amend it
to allow
to allow borrowing but certainly if we
were to borrow now would
it seem to be a um as good a time as any
as any given given as you say the
historic low interest rates but
but there is obviously no decision at
this point and as i say it would require
a formal approval of a revised strategy
where we
to suggest that that was the the most
cost-effective way to move forward
thank you thank you naomi
councillor mcpherson thank you chairman
um first of all can i thank officers
for putting in so much of their time
into
the working group um i just want to say
um
as you can see from the side of the
document a lot of action
took place during those meetings it was
actually a mammoth task some of those
meetings went on for over two
hours um and working groups are open to
all members
um to come along to and contribute to so
i just wanted to
make that clear for anybody um listening
um also with regard to the mention of
the
um 40 pound around the green
uh waist bins can i just say that that
is not predetermined
it is in the report but also as another
councillor
actually mentioned under 4.2 also
included
is mentioned of the environment bill
and there will be a consultation going
out to the public
and one mention of it is the green waste
may be considered
as free for um all residents across the
country
so nothing is predetermined by any means
in that report
thank you very much chairman thank you
councillor
uh members i can't see any other people
indicating to
to speak is there anybody sonja have i
missed anyone
yes certainly thank you chairman um i'd
just like to thank the working group for
everything it was
quite onerous and um it was it took a
long time
um special thanks to marcus hotten for
such a
a concise report and especially tonight
to leslie for
stepping forward in marcus's place thank
you all okay
okay members if there's no more
questions and i would
point out this is a recommendation
nothing is set in stone nothing has been
approved
there is a recommendation on paul page
7.18 of the report paragraph
14.1 that would be recommended to the
council that the waste and recycling
strategy be adopted
would you please raise your hand if you
want a recorded vote
i can't see anybody on that basis
would you please if your support this
being put forward to full council as a
recommendation
please indicate now by raising your blue
hand
[Music]
uh
okay you got that sonia
yes if um if if people could lower that
if people could now lower your hands
anybody not supporting this
recommendation would you please raise
the blue hand now
thank you chairman and anybody
abstaining
please take your hand down if there is
anybody and then anybody
who is abstaining please raise the blue
hand now
thank you chairman that's um that's
approved
thank you members excuse me mr chairman
could you give us the
the numbers yes certainly sonia could
you would you known us but
yes uh there there were 11 voting uh
11 voting for zero against
and there were uh there were four
uh sorry three that did not actually
vote
so i assume it's abstained
well i'm not sure if you counted my hand
um sonia
so could you check that because i
certainly didn't abstain
okay members if you're sorry if i make
payments well on a point of order i
think you'll find that
i'm not sure if counselor hazel would
was able to use it either because i
noticed in his screen he was
holding his hand up so i'm not sure if
he was voting for or his machine wasn't
working
okay members can we please if you are in
support of this
recommendation please indicate by
raising your blue hand
now
and sonia i can see councillor hazelwood
is raising his
hand okay
and so is joe mcpherson and councilman
mcpherson sonia
the reason i'm doing that because my
blue hand won't come up
okay so there's all the blue hands plus
council macpherson
and councillor hazelwood okay please
lower your
blue hands members
yes chairman okay any members voting
against the recommendation please raise
the blue hand now
oh no hans ray's chair okay and any
members
abstaining please raise the blue hand
now
yeah no hands raised chairman okay sonia
could you please give us the figures
then
chairman the 13-0 uh with
with uh with with one extension
okay thank you members
moving on to agenda item eight the key
decisions document
mr chairman before we move on i'm a
little concerned that
a vote was potentially miscounted um
obviously in this matter it wouldn't
have made a great deal of difference
because of the
significant uh majority but i do think
that
we need to have a system where
that a the numbers should be given
anyway and
b the members have a choice of
according to the monetary office that
are voting for
are floating against abstaining
or not registering a vote and i think we
need to be very clear that every
member has had their opportunity to be
counted
on on these votes it does raise concern
and perhaps you could look at it after
the meeting
thank you thank you council mrs mason
i'm
sure sonia has taken that on board as uh
as uh
ms law so i'm sure that will be taken
into account for
future meetings thank you
agenda item number eight key decision
documents as far as i can see there are
three
items on there members uh the first
is the disposal of the redundant crown
hill public conveniences
this report will go to the executive in
the new year
there's the leisure contract there is a
report to tomorrow's executive
outlining the options for the leisure
services provision from the 1st of
april 2021 and also
the suspension of parking charges on
saturday before on the saturdays before
christmas
this decision has now been taken members
is there anybody that wishes to raise
any points on those three items if so
please
indicate by raising your blue hand
cancel the hook way
made in relation to free parking in the
run-up to christmas
uh on saturdays um i know it's been
advertised now
um but um it's kind of
um something that is
um what we're carrying on
as per normal in innocent
circumstances which are abnormal and um
there was um
the idea floated that uh maybe this
decision
could have come before review so we
could looked at it and maybe made an
alternative um options um bearing in
mind that uh
a lot of the businesses that were shut
due to the
um recent lockdown there were sort of
like um small
um smaller shops um sort of
smaller traders and we could have
possibly looked at this um and maybe
come to an alternative thing maybe we
could have had free car parking in the
right
christmas for all days not just
saturdays uh to help
businesses in the run-up to christmas so
um
it's it may be sort of like
shutting the gate after the horses
bolted but it's it's something that
um um we could have possibly looked at
but
uh i don't know if anyone else has got
any comments in relation to this thank
you
council ahoy
sorry i realized i was speaking to a
muted mic there
um there's two things one one to put up
what counselor porque said but i've got
another issue on
one of the other key decisions so um
i'll just back up what counselor hawkway
said i think the um
for some reason the um the free parking
december has become very late again
obviously it used to be made as an
urgent decision and said i think it was
pointed out that it shouldn't really be
urgent because we know when christmas is
each year it doesn't change and i'm not
sure i was made so late perhaps there
was an excuse around that pandemic
but if it's being made so late it has
effectively that
it's sort of to members it's the same as
an urgent decision
and i i do question why it was made so
late and perhaps
that could be answered now um
i would expect it to be made much
earlier i know that it's made around the
budget
but i i think this should have been made
at least a month or two earlier than it
was
and that would allow members to to look
at it properly
thank you i really can't answer that
counselor
i don't know why it was made when it was
when it was made um can we go back to
the um
i mean i'm just answering this one first
of all i don't know when it was made
it it is as you say something that has
almost become the norm over many years
um but it's i think there's a fine line
at the moment
that the the council has lost huge
amounts of money
in parking revenue and there is the fine
line between trying to
support the high streets and uh i think
that's a
a situation that is going to be running
for the next few months because
if you can guarantee that this is the
end of all the lockdowns and all the
tier systems well good luck because i'm
not convinced that it is
that's a personal view i've got nothing
to support it right councilor wilkinson
and my comment is in relation to um
the second item which is regarding the
leisure contract
um members will know no doubt because
they've
they've been circulated that i have two
questions on notices for the executive
in relation
to item eight in the end of tomorrow
night one of which is in relation to the
extension
of the leisure uh contract the only
reason i raise it now chairman is
because it's in front of us on review
yeah are we gonna be voting for this or
voting we're making any comment and i
just want to be careful
in some opposition here no i what we're
doing as far as i'm aware
son you could maybe want to correct me
these were issues that have been raised
and were key decisions um
and we bring these forward on a regular
basis to ensure basically they don't
don't just
move into the ether this is an update on
these particular items i know councillor
hoy wants to come back on another one
this is uh an issue uh we've talked
about the disposal of the toilet
the uh leisure contract this is the
update it's up for to the exact so this
is the noting purposes then i'll take it
yeah and and we can raise the questions
thank you sorry michael i i forgot you
you had something else you want to raise
perhaps before i move on to council mrs
mason you'd like to come back michael
yeah thank you so you you may have um
perhaps i switched off at some point but
you said we've discussed what's going to
raise already
i was going to raise the um first
condition about the sound of
at crown hill um this
was that the case or did i misunderstand
you now as far as i'm aware
i do not know uh i don't know if anybody
else knows anything but i certainly know
nothing
further than what it says there that a
report regarding
uh the disposal of the crown hill
toilets will go to the executive next
year
i've heard nothing other than what i've
just read
is the first but it's still the first of
december rather than november today
and um i'm not sure where the report is
this is
something that i i think i'm
keen to look at a bit more but obviously
we haven't got the report yet
to look at it so perhaps it's something
i'll be possibly looking to bring to the
um
review committee when it when a decision
is actually made i i don't disagree with
you michael
and it can also say that because of the
situations
that we've seen in the la well in the
last 48 hours where we've seen 25 000
people
being made redundant the impact on the
high street
what was a what was the plan a few
months ago may not be the plan anymore
i don't i honestly don't know yeah okay
it's just
for warning that i'd be looking at keep
an eye on it that's all thank you yeah
no i
fully agree uh councillor wilson is that
hand still from the same one or is there
something else
no i lower it sorry check
sorry council mrs mason yeah thank you
mr chairman
i'd like to support the
um issues raised by councillor hook
way and hoy regarding the parking i
think it's regrettable that our
portfolio holders don't know when
christmas is it's been pointed out
before
it was brought forward and done in a
timely fashion
it hasn't been done this year i
appreciate
that the council is losing revenue but
we have had a considerable sums in
excess i believe of 2 million from the
government to assist us in our finances
as you say the short-term impact and
you've said this yourself on the high
street of the
number of redundancies is going to have
a high impact
which if we don't support our
businesses we'll have a knock on
impact on our revenues um
and i i do think that the council missed
an opportunity to help residents that
are finding it difficult
and businesses that are finding it
difficult and it is regrettable that the
decision was made so late
that that discussion couldn't have been
made properly
thank you thank you
okay members i think if there's no other
questions i think we've
we've noted all your comments um
and we'll work on to the agenda for the
the work plan members are there any
questions on the work plan
council mrs mason
yes i'm quite concerned about this
we have items on the work plan that
haven't been allocated
time the asset strategy the car parking
update animal welfare charter
the local um electricity bill and yet in
november this council saw fit
to cancel the november meeting and not
hold a review committee at all
the review committee is an important
committee
it is the committee that overviews and
scrutinizes
the work of the council i've never
before
known a meeting of such a committee
um counsellor and it causes a great deal
of concern
the other thing that concerns me
is that in march mid mark
we were due to have a report circulated
about the management of open spaces on
new
um bills and the
legal officers had been tasked with
providing us
information this was not done and i
think in view of the
the situation that we all found
ourselves in though
that was before the uh pandemic it was
due but
never nonetheless i think it was
understandable it was left
however this was brought up again in
august it was brought up
with the acting managing director in
august and again in november
but it appears that we don't have the
resources
to deal with the workload that we have
so what i'd like to do as a matter of
urgency is put the resources
for the work on the council work plan
because if we can't
undertake the work that we're tasked
with doing there is a fundamental
problem
so i think this council should as a
matter of urgency this committee rather
should look
at the resourcing
and i'd like an explanation as well as
to why
the report that was due in mid-march
we're now in december has still not been
provided
and sonia could you make a note of this
so that we can pass this on to the
uh executive and the group and the
council leader for his comments in due
course
um yes i mean in terms of the uh
specific
issue that uh that counselor mrs mason
raises around the um
around um the the management of um of
those
those spaces etc um uh
it's unfortunate that uh mr hotten uh uh
is absent from this evening's meeting
because i know that
um he you know he he would have been
able to provide an update this evening
objection to that mr hudson on the 6th
of august
was asked to contact me within a week to
determine the situation
that was in august we are now in
december and i've not heard from him
so i don't think that's an acceptable
reason okay well i've i've
i'm asking for a review the
review committee to look at staffing
resources because so far it says that we
haven't got the staff to carry out basic
functions
well i i will ask this gut to be
highlighted
to the council leader and to put it to
the executive
or the appropriate bodies that will be
looking at resourcing of the council
councillor mrs mcpherson thank you
chairman
really it's just a polite reminder and a
point of order
could fellow councillors please follow
protocol
raise hand wait for the chairman to come
to them
and not speak over especially other
councillors and the chairman as well
thank you chairman
okay thank you councilman
okay members are there any other issues
that wish to
be raised mr chairman can i also let you
put on the work plan
i've asked i've not you said you'll take
it to the executive
we've tried that we've tried
he's aware of the situation thank you
well we can raise it then with him
directly
if necessary i will raise it with him
directly myself
thank you mr chairman appreciate it
so chairman i had been indicating i
think that the hand is playing up
somewhat oh right yeah over to you then
council away
um strangely i was going to raise the
issue around the open
spaces working group which is the one
council mrs mason is talking about which
hasn't
met since the first meeting
on that basis i echo the same concerns
that okay
although they're working there's been a
couple of working groups which has done
quite a substantial amount of work
the the scrutiny committee in itself has
been rather bare
in what it's been doing in my opinion um
i i really think we should put this as
an um
for the committee for the next meeting
the resources not just take it to the
leader but
i would like it well i i'll take it to
the leader and council
the reason i'm reluctant
because i'm not chairman of this
committee to put any more
uh items on the january uh
agenda is quite simply that i believe
his personal view that there will be
quite a lot of questions answers
presentation
needed in relation to the review of the
kovid situation
past present and in the future and i
think that could become quite an
extensive meeting in itself
and i don't want to help me say cram
anybody's questioning time or going
through this i think this could be quite
a serious and lengthy uh review
of of the council procedures what we've
done what we haven't done
and and go from there but i'm reluctant
to commit
uh councillor burton for for anything
further
if he wishes to do that when he's fully
recovered
we can raise it with him and if he
wishes to include it in the agenda
so be it but i think at the moment i i
would be reluctant
in it but let's say if councillor burton
wants to take it on board fine
i i do take your point um therefore at
the very least could we just add this to
the
to the um the working
the work plan yeah there's a nice
at least it is not not forgotten or
forgotten
yep no pro thank you
sorry i'm on the mute button's paying up
i will raise this with the council
leader
okay members if there's nothing else
i can't see anybody indicating i will
close the meeting at 2037 and say thank
you very much for attending
thank you thank you